hello and welcome to this video playing
Killy yeah I laid him recently yeah I
think it was a it was some kind of some
kind of dash mm-hmm I playing again a
sideline 94 it's a bit put your risky
delaying your development that much so
just III c4 or is there something better
efore probably not wow you can afford
that okay developing nothing weakening
yourself everything at the same time
that's good okay I have a hard time to
relieve edit so let's see Bishop c4 I
guess I think I remember this guy he
played in the same completely reckless
manner earlier in an earlier game just
dashing out instant moves and being
basically lost out of the opening so
let's see how to how to punish mmm
Queenie tune probably getting would be
five as a possibility
and you form maybe d5 sis playable
that's really amazing a six
yeah i'm just i just want to open up the
whole thing and checkmate
let's see what we need we are like b5
Bishop g5 but I don't know it looks it
looks demo for FY well okay and we'll
give one maybe main the main danger in
such a position is that you are so
overwhelmed by all of the possibilities
that you have that you just lose on time
it happened to me more than once so
let's see him he can actually cancel our
next move
champion purely positionally it's not
not clear that this is enough like II 5
and so on it's all nice but not [ __ ]
meeting him what if I can take is 64
look to a check book THX and then 95
check take special chinks yeah probably
i have to have to be good here i'm i'm
waiting any longer he will probably
really just castle
so takes root da check and then I mean I
can't even think about taking on h eight
and then 95 check but I think not g5
checking me Utley is probably better so
check check check and now he has to step
into those discoveries what is best
let's check it King e7 can you go King
e7 night x e6 check King e6 this is
really survivable I can check him on
g-form king of seven mmm I don't
co-direct win
I can take age seven thirsty em take h7
then back to f7 check king is seven if I
go back it just goes back to have Sam
that's not going to lead to much if he
takes with the King I have 96 double
check if he takes with the rook and I
take see success also pretty pretty
dangerous I also think if if five looks
pretty if I threatens 94 maybe this is
right okay I cannot calculate it let's
go for it who in the eighth seemed see
as he expected that move if I take is
six now I can also just go back on ID
494 496 check is stronger check rinse
the queen that wins the Queen
check checkmate Oh mate and you have to
develop at some point you cannot just
weak in your position and move
everything three times and so on no
that's really weird c5 I really in three
seconds this is totally enter positional
and to open up the position like that
okay I went back maybe we can I can even
improve here Bishop g3 or so but I
thought that looks kind of normal and
why they at least has a very strong
compensation you form 20-f four is six
sound so after a 6-bit should be six
does win yeah I mean 96 is what the
engine is giving edit assesses them
first assessment is equal equal is
funnier I mean whites compensation is
very clear but now still have to still
have to find some win but this does win
pigs can check 95 junking e79 Texas six
check is Johnny okay I didn't see it I
really didn't see how this wins check
here here I careful I didn't see Queen
FYI forgot about this idea this chest is
check and now queen gerri checa okay
this is the point I have to take the
whole stuff here and then give this this
check okay okay that's not so easy but
what about my move is it winning as well
it is winning as well that's good so at
least wins the Queen here 96 again wins
but chance also completely winning King
here check this and
I'm winning the Queen and have a have an
ongoing attack yeah that was just a bit
with too many liberties taken in the
opening even though I mean the computer
is very often giving those kind of
things as kind of kind of still okay but
it's it's very difficult to play like
that as a human player okay well thanks
for watching